ok let's get into audience questions for
the week some relevant to the 2020
Democratic campaign and others not so
relevant to it which we'll get to okay
first question David will Beto
O'Rourke's campaign last more or less
than one month okay I get it you are
asking whether better or works campaign
is even going to get going
number one from the early fundraising
numbers that we've seen if they are to
be believed and I think generally
speaking they are to be believed it does
seem like his campaign is going to last
more than a month but I get the question
let me interpret the question more as do
I think that better or works campaign
has some kind of broader staying power
beyond just being yet another person
dropping their name into the Hat but
unlikely to see much happen as a result
we did see a couple of missteps from
Beto O'Rourke he answered some questions
in a kind of strange way I saw one
question from a few days ago where he
was asked about a woman running mate for
VP and he's sort of fumbled it but he
also didn't really say anything that was
that was too crazy he just sort of
reacted a little bit weirdly people have
been making fun of the way that he just
sticky lates with his hands and stood on
a countertop in a restaurant saying if a
woman had done that it would have been
outraged but because it was better or
Rorick a man it was seen as either a
power move or acceptable or something so
far the strongest criticisms of Beto
O'Rourke are ones that I don't actually
know if represent a liability to him
which is that he's sort of a corporatist
and he's sort of a centrist and I
generally agree with those perspectives
but I don't think that at this point in
time it's actually going to hold him
back in the 2020 Democratic primary not
because of the country or rather the
Democratic Party hasn't moved to the
left it has moved to the left but
because it is so much about personality
and enchant intangibles once you get
beyond some sort of basic policy
positions wait
he more or less checks the boxes on so I
think that at this point in time we're
dealing with basically a name
recognition game um in that sense he has
more name recognition than some of the
other candidates because of his 2018
race against Ted Cruz which he
ultimately lost at the beginning of the
week I did a story on favorability and
net favorability among all voters is
non-existent for every Democratic count
candidate other than Joe Biden among all
voters Joe Biden has positive
favorability everybody else has that
negative favorability but within the
Democratic primary voters beta or work
is actually doing okay in terms of
favorability and named recognizability
so I I don't believe that he is going to
just disappear in the way that some are
thinking and hoping that he is going to
he is not in my top candidates would I
vote for him over Trump of course I
would but that's not even really a
question at this point so Beto or Oracle
will last longer than a month
to answer the question as asked anyone
saying he has no shot I just don't know
how you can say that at this point if
you look historically at who has been
leading in March of the year before the
election compared to who has ultimately
secured the nomination in the following
summer you can't really do deuce too
much from march of the previous year
polling I don't totally understand the
pitch or the reason why someone would
support Beto or Roarke over some of the
other candidates I don't think you know
I'm not big on identity arguments but if
you ask me what's the most appealing
thing about Beto or org
I think his youth is one of the most
appealing things in the sense that I
don't find his policy positions
particularly compelling or uniquely
interesting his political experience is
not particularly compelling to me so if
you say even though you're not an
identity politics guy David what is his
most appealing trait it might be his
youth and the sort of energy that that
he brings I see him I've said I don't
really want to talk about
b.p stuff for the time being it's really
about who's the candidate going to be
but I see Beto
O'Rourke as a front-runner on the JV
team the junior varsity team rather than
a sort of a list or varsity team
frontrunner and oftentimes being a JV
frontrunner can make you unappealing
vice presidential pick because you can
be a net positive you can bring
something that the primary can that it
doesn't have could be age or youth
rather depending on who the candidate
ultimately is without taking away what
might be seen as too much attention and
I mean look look at Pence one of the
best things about Pence if you're Donald
Trump and you're such a incipient
narcissist is Pence doesn't really get a
lot of attention he doesn't take away a
lot of attention from Donald Trump that
can be good for the personality of the
person who is the candidate it can also
just fit well in terms of how it keeps
the campaign on message without too much
distraction so I think Beto Rourke is
here for some time although maybe not a
very very long time and will ultimately
see could be months when you buy one of
those variety packs of socks there's
bound to be one pair that you don't
really like as much as the rest
but with dollar sock crew you can build
your own package of socks starting as
low as a dollar sixty a pair and choose
from classic patterns or quirky vibrant
designs shop dollar sock crew calm now
and receive 30% off your first order
with the code Pakman that's dollar sock
crew com code PA que ma N